wir jetzt mal was was wieder 1000
Shitstorms bringt aber ich sage es
trotzdem vielleicht müssen wir
tatsächlich mal drüber nachrechnen
nachdenken ob die Flüchtlingskonvention
die Europäische Menschenrechtskonvention
so noch funktionieren ich meine die
Flüchtlingskonvention kommt aus den 50er
Jahren die ist unter dem Eindruck des
Zweiten Weltkrieges entstanden übrigens
geilste ursprünglich nur für Europa und
die Frage ist ja macht das im Jahr 2023
so mit diesen individuellen Verfahren
monatelang ohne Klarheit für alle
Beteiligten und mit dem Botschaften die
sie sendet sind oder wäre es nicht
besser wie sie auch gesagt haben wir
arbeiten mit klaren Kontingenten
Größenordnungen zu denen wir uns
verpflichten wo die UN auch auswählt
nach bestimmten Kriterien welche
Menschen am dringendsten auch eine
Perspektive nach Europa hinein bekommen
sollten haben aber an der Grenze eben
auch die klare Botschaft über diesen
Landweg außer aus der Ukraine ist jetzt
mal wer über den Landweg kommt per se
schon mindestens mal durch zwei drei
vier sichere Länder gegangen